all right star
star star where'd you grow up where you
from originally um
east tennessee
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents growing up
not the whole time um i grew up
in um like the first 12 years of my life
i had two
moms um it was my sister and i
and then um they split up
and i moved in with my dad to
another town in east tennessee um
with my father my stepmother
and my two brothers um
and that's when my dad became like a
bigger
presence in my life
[Music]
he and my mom split when i was two
because he um
he was pretty violent and um with all of
us
uh so yeah
she moved on and
found happy i suppose and left you with
your dad
um no i mean like she left him and
um the first 12 years of my life were
like blissfully happy uh
it was my choice to move in with my dad
and probably
probably the first worst mistake of my
life
what do you say that um he was
he was very um
physically and verbally abusive
emotionally
[Music]
um
but i guess it took me a long time
to stop being so angry now that i'm on
the
when i became a mother um got
four kids now um
my parents were really young when they
had me they were 16 and 17.
um and i think that they just
uh they both made the best
out of a bad situation and did their
best and something about me just
um tripped my dad's trigger out of all
four of us kids i'm the only one he laid
hands on
um to the best of my knowledge he never
he never hit my stepmom um
it's kind of a common theme growing up
like my first boyfriend in high school
middle school in high school it was four
years long
that turned physically abusive too he
beat the crap out of me um
and then my husband 11 years we were
married
he had never hit a woman before in his
life but
it took less than a year um for him to
start
lashing out at me so
excuse me um so i'm
like um i'm not some like fragile victim
that thinks that
you know everything's my fault but i do
think like
three completely different men i'm the
common denominator
like there's gotta be something about me
that
um i guess like at a minimum brings out
the worst
in men so the abuse from your
father was mostly physical or was it
sexual or anything else
um no it was physical
mostly um but it was pretty bad
um i remember
when i was like 16 being called into the
principal's office
at school
i was taking a cna course at the time
and i guess
my teacher the nurse saw bruises on
my face even though i tried to cover
them up with makeup
and there was a counselor and a
principal in there and
they asked me what happened to my face
and i lied and said that
a big bin of ketchup fell on it at work
um
i don't know why but i always
wanted to um i never wanted to see him
in trouble i guess some part of me even
the first time that he ever hit me in
the face
i was 12 even then i didn't
i didn't tell anybody i didn't um i
didn't want to see him in trouble
i just
i just didn't want him to do it again
and i guess i thought
like i mean i loved him too i didn't i
didn't want
to see him in trouble and i guess i
thought like
[Applause]
if i said something that i maybe get
taken away from my family or
things would get worse
so i'm not new as angry now as i was
back then
but one thing that does [ __ ] me up
pretty bad
is i have um my oldest child my son
he um about a year ago
um at almost exactly the same age i was
the first time dad hit me
did exactly the same thing i did to get
hit
and it was so very easy not
to hit him oh
i was i was angry and um
disappointed but all i had to do was
look at his face and
um
no part of me wanted to strike him or
hurt him
and that kind of sent me back at square
one
like i thought i was done being angry
but um
i'm not because now because i made
excuses all this time like i was just
you know a difficult teenager and i
wouldn't listen and i was rebellious and
whatever but
i have one of those at home and
like i said it's so easy not to hit them
so
i don't understand why it was so easy to
hit me
so much and so
hard i guess
okay so um yeah i had my bags packed
about a month before i turned 18. um i
was ready to leave
and um i left and i got my own apartment
um got pregnant with my son when i was
18.
um i was
by the time he was about nine months old
i was working full time
at a nursing home going to school for
nursing
full-time and i was a single mom
and then the drug started i got hurt at
work
and they put me out of work for
six weeks and
gave me pain pills um
[Music]
i remember when i ran out of pain pills
um
[Music]
i thought i was losing my mind i didn't
realize what
was actually happening i didn't know
anything about withdrawal um
even though most of my family members
were junkies i
that just wasn't part of my world um i
was gonna be
a nurse and be somebody right so
um my aunt i guess recognized what was
wrong with me
and handed me um a much stronger pill
and she was like here take this it'll
make you feel better
and i remember it did um in a matter of
minutes i was in the floor playing with
my son and cleaning the house and i felt
like superwoman
and quickly within probably
three or four months of that day i went
from
just taking pills to snorting them to
slamming them and then it was heroin
because it was cheaper
then my son's father filed for emergency
custody when he found
out and i went to a 90-day
inpatient program because it was that or
lose my son
and i completed it
came out and got high
like two days later
started stealing from the people that i
love the most
and screwing everybody over and
um it all pretty much caught up to me
um so i took off for oklahoma
which is where my biological grandfather
and his wife my memo
um and my aunt lived and my baby cousins
um my plan was to run away and
get better and come back for my son um
and it didn't exactly work that way
um i knew from an early age
that my grandfather was a pedophile
but he
he was allowed in our home until i was
probably
looking at the pictures probably six or
seven and then mama cut off all contact
with them um
[Music]
and it just so happens that the
neighborhood that my father lived in
my grandfather's best friend also lived
in and
when i met him he put me in contact with
my family from oklahoma and from like 12
until 18
um had a relationship with all of them
by phone
um and i would meet up with them sneak
and meet up with them when they come to
tennessee
um and he seemed like
he was changed like he was a
just a great big he was like six foot
six or
six foot seven something he was huge and
he played the guitar and he sang and he
was a comedian
and like um
[Music]
super charismatic and just the kind of
person that
that you want to be around um so i
looked forward to his visits
even though um i think i was 14
and it was in the front yard of his best
friend's house in my subdivision
he was going to leave and everybody was
inside but there were neighbors outside
and um he he said let me get one more
hug from you before you go
and you leaned up against the tree and
he kissed me and i went to kiss him on
the cheek
but he turned his head and he caught me
on the mouth
and i remember it
the kiss lasted way too long and he
stuck his tongue in my mouth and
um i just kind of
just kind of pulled away and and jetted
i was like bye pebble
see you later and didn't speak to him
for a while but stayed in contact with
my grandma and my aunt
um
and when i did like get back in contact
with him he acted like it never happened
and i guess in my head i mean
i guess i made myself believe that it
was um an accident or a mistake like he
didn't really mean to do it or something
but
by the time i was 20 and i lost custody
of my son and gone through rehab and it
didn't work and then got out and
screwed up again and felt desperate and
like i had nowhere else to go
um i was getting drug tested regularly
and i knew
i was gonna fail the drug test and at
that point
probably lose all access to my son
it was worth the risk going out to
oklahoma and i was an adult by then so i
thought like all the
all the appeal would be gone for my
grandfather
um that there was nothing to worry about
and they
welcomed me with open arms
i still very much regret going out there
but
i guess just like with anything and
laughing with anybody
there's good in most bad
there's there was a lot of good
and a lot of healing that came out of
that situation but
um
the bad definitely outweighed the good
um
i stayed there for
three three and a half maybe four months
i know i turned
21 while i was there um
and for the first month month and a half
nothing happened at all with him
everything was fine
um i got a job i was working and i was
part of the family my mom made me go to
church even though i was like
a hardcore atheist pissed me off
didn't want to go but i did it
out of respect for her and quickly got
like the hang of things
and um started to feel like a normal
person again
they even the kids pretty much
just breathe life into me like
every day they tell me they love me and
he would do like on sundays when it was
time to go to church
i never wore dresses ever and i hated my
my name because it was such a
you know what the word is maybe
masculine name
um and everybody back home in tennessee
had a nickname for me that was
even worse so he would take pictures
he'd be waiting on
the front porch when we left for church
i'd take a picture of me in dresses and
say
he'd turn the camera around and make me
look at it and he'd say
that's a lady right there like you're a
lady
remember that your lady um
and i started to believe in i started to
feel like one
we also had a lot of conversations he
was really open about
he never denied anything that he did um
to any of us i guess i forgot i should
back up when i was
five my sister was four
was the first time um
[Music]
that he crossed any lines with us
um
mama had to took us to oklahoma for a
visit
and um
we woke up one morning real early before
everybody else and we went to the
bathroom
my sister and i together in their
bathroom instead of
a door it had a shower curtain hanging
as the door
one of the clear ones that you could
kind of see through and we could see him
sitting on the toilet
and um my sister opened the curtain a
little bit
and we saw him and jumped back and we
were like oh no and
you know when to go back to the bedroom
and he was like no no it's okay come
here
and we turned around and he had opened
the curtain all the way
and he was standing there um
looming over us like six and a half feet
tall
but naked um
just steady jacking it like we were his
wife or something standing in front of
him and
he grabbed me by the wrist and pulled me
closer to him and put my hand
on his penis and
um
well that lasted for what felt like an
eternity he had a sick smile on his face
the whole time
um i guess eventually i unfroze
my sister i remember the look on her
face she was
just frozen like with
this horrified terrified look on her
face
and um i guess when i finally snapped
out of it i
i jerked away and i turned around and i
took off running and i made it almost
back to the bedroom and i realized she
wasn't with me
and i went back to get her and she was
standing there in front of him
he didn't grab her he didn't make her
touch him
but he was doing
the same thing in front of her and she
standing there watching like with her
little
jaw dropped open and i grabbed her by
the arm and i pulled her
and we ran back to the room my mom
[Music]
and we were sleeping in and
i thought we just hit under the covers
and went back to sleep but
when we went to trial a few years ago
for my baby cousin who testified against
him who prosecuted him we went to
testify on her behalf
mom told me that she was like oh my god
i can't
believe you remember that we actually
had told her what he had done and
i don't remember this but she said that
as soon as we came in there and told her
she packed our stuff and we left and
i think she let him come over maybe one
time after that
and that's when it ended so
going back and and there was some funky
[ __ ] in between but nothing like
nothing like horrible like what my
mother went through um
or my ants um
he did some unspeakable [ __ ] to them
their entire lives um
[Music]
so it was about a month and a half into
my stay in oklahoma and
um
he took me to meet a friend of his
to see about buying a house there my
goal i
like i said i got a job my goal was to
move my son out there
my son signed the papers on the first
house and
he took me up in the woods behind the
house to show me around
i remember he had to unlock a chain
on a gate and drive the car up
a ways um we got out we were walking
and i remember walking and walking and
walking and thinking where
where are we going like this is oklahoma
it's not
tennessee there's nothing to see shit's
flat and ugly like where are we going
and um
[Music]
i didn't hear him walking anymore so i
turned around and
he always did this thing even whenever
um i was a young teenager that day in
his neighbor's yard he would always
put his arm up on a tree or um
like the post on a front porch or
something
i don't know now looking back if it was
to try to make himself look bigger or
what but
he didn't need to be any bigger to be
intimidating
but he had his arm up on a tree and he
had that look on his face again
and i remember um
again i was 20 or 21 at this time
i remember um thinking
run something in my gut told me that
something bad was about to happen i
never imagined it was that
but um i knew i knew it was something i
i didn't need to stick around for it but
i froze like i was
five years old again
um and he
went in for the kill
i think it must have been a sunday
because i had a skirt on
and those were the only days i wore a
dress or a skirt
um he was never violent
at all just
imposing if that makes sense like
he didn't have to be violent you just
knew you didn't have a choice like
the way he moved with you
it never even crossed my mind
to try to like fight back
or scream or holler um
later on when it started happening
regularly
i did try to fight back some wriggle
away whatever but it did no good but
that day
um
[Music]
i didn't cry i just
laid there
and kind of
just took it like i did back in
tennessee when i was on dope
when i had a needle in my arm slept with
some pretty disgusting
vile men for drugs or money
and it's not like in the movies like
where they make it look like
you can completely leave what your
situation what's going on
um but you kinda can
so i kinda did um i just
waited for it to be over i remember
thinking
it felt like a dream like this isn't
really happening
um not not because
i didn't think he was capable of it i
just thought
it wouldn't happen because i was grown
i wasn't a little girl and didn't have
that same appeal anymore and
in the time that it took for him to get
done doing what he did
[Music]
all every bit of
the positivity and the encouragement and
the
love that he um had shown me to that
point
um and just left
i was angry it felt like he
was fake and phony and it felt like
i felt like i was the same
dope sick junkie that pulled into his
driveway 900 miles from home
a month or so earlier um
like it was nothing but lies
and i think the only reason it stopped
is because he heard a car coming and it
was the landowner
um he jumped up real quick
and he was like hurry hurry get get your
clothes back on hurry up come on let's
go
and i couldn't hurry i remember
everything was in slow motion
um
but i got up and i started to follow him
out of the
the woods and
he had given me a ring like a week
earlier
that looking back looked a lot like an
engagement ring
um but he said again i was a lady
and i deserved to have pretty things so
i was walking out of the woods behind
him and i took the ring
and took it off my hand and i threw it
down
in the woods
[Music]
and walked out with him
to meet that man again and acted like
nothing
had ever happened like he was just
showing me around
um
i don't know why i didn't leave that day
but at this point everybody back home
was still furious with me
and and made it clear
that i wasn't welcome in their homes and
with good reason i deserved it
um i was a horrible person back then
i i can't think of anybody i love today
that i didn't hurt
in some way back then
the second encounter with him um we
stayed in a tiny house
very poor i slept with my baby cousin
in the same bed with her in the same
room
in a tiny little bed she was a tiny
little girl
um i thought she was seven
but doing the math now i think she was
five years old at the time
and apparently and they had custody of
her he
was molesting her from the age of like
two
to thirteen and that's what the trial
was over
um i thought i knew what to look for and
i thought
i thought that he wasn't messing with
her but he was but
in my mind that night she was still
completely naive and i wanted to keep it
that way i
i also remembered my memo saying
that she slept with one arm on him at
night
to make sure if he got out of bed
that she would wake up and if he was
gone from the room too long
she'd know to go look and check and see
if
years ago if her daughters were safe or
now if her granddaughter was safe
so when he came in our room that night i
panicked he came in
and nothing but [ __ ] raunchy old
tidy whities and
um um all i could think was
my baby cousin's gonna wake up and she's
gonna see this
and if she doesn't mama will wake up and
she'll walk in and see this
and she'll think that i'm
that i'm this horrible person that's
doing this because i want to um
that night i cried because
like i said she was late my cousin was
laying
in the bed right beside me like her body
was touching mine we were so close
um he climbed on top of me and
uh never hit him but i was pushing him
trying to push him off of me
and i pulled my knees up to my chest
trying to get him off of me
and but he was so he was so huge he was
there was no getting away from him
um his hands were so big
that you could drop a quarter through
his pinky ring
um he was just a massive man i didn't
want to make any noise because i didn't
want to
i didn't want to wake anybody up and
ultimately he got what he wanted that
night again
the next day i woke up furious
and i went out to his shed where he was
working
um he was building hammered dulcimers by
hand um and i told him
that he was never
i basically i basically said um
on my terms only like if this shit's
gonna happen while i'm here
it's gonna happen when i say and where i
say
and that that means not
with any chance of my baby cousin being
exposed to it or
my mama getting her heart ripped out so
he pretty much it he pretty much adhered
to my rules and i know that to most
people this is gonna sound ridiculous
and they're
gonna be like you were 21 years old
why didn't you just leave why didn't you
go to the cops why didn't you
tell your grandmother why did why all
these things
i can't answer those questions i don't
know
i only know that i really truly felt
like i couldn't and like i was stuck and
a big part of me still
felt like a child inside and
you have to understand too that to this
day
i've never met a more
like i say this
every time i talk about it but i don't
know how to put it
stealthy predator in my life he was
the best of the best in terms of being
like a predator and a sociopath he
he would bend
grown men to his will just with a few
words there was no telling him no
and i guess if you don't know somebody
like that in your life it's probably
hard to understand but
that aside um
[Music]
he never came in my room again with my
baby cousin in there
and he generally always let me know it
was time when my grandmother was gone
so this started to be um
a regular thing i can't tell you how
many times i had sex with my grandfather
my biological grandfather or
allowed him to have sex with me probably
probably 50 or 60 times
while i was there um
i was able to get my son for two weeks
um
during the time i stayed in oklahoma and
on
the trip to go get him my grandfather
took me
and he said that it had to be just me
and him
um that he had business to take care of
back in tennessee when we got here
and he stopped to get a hotel
which wasn't necessary because he used
to brag about how he didn't
need to stop and sleep he could do the
drive round trip no problem
and it was during that trip that um
in that hotel room for
i don't know close to 24 hours it was
non-stop
over and over again like
this man was in his late 50s i think
maybe
i want to say he was born
42 or something um
[Music]
he was an old man but like the sex drive
of an 18 year old
he did things that um if i wasn't
if i was super uncomfortable with them
if it hurt whatever if i tried to get
away
again it's not like he hit me or
anything but he
would just pull me back and
make me do it anyway um or flip me over
whatever and
i remember during during that like 24
hours in the motel room
um it just
went on and on and on and
i think some part of me just caved
and i
tried to
got to the point where i couldn't escape
it mentally so i had to be present for
it
and um it's so [ __ ] hard to say
um yeah
the first orgasm i ever had was
with my grandfather
and
i guess i got so used to
the fact that this was happening
and it wasn't gonna stop
that i got kind of numb to the horror of
it all
and
um there were
there were times that i did my but
i guess no both
my body and my mind i guess
liked what he was doing um
[Music]
and i hated myself for that i think i
still do
it was revolting and disgusting
and that's a wild thing like to be
to like to like what somebody's doing
to you but be repulsed by it at the same
time
sorry can you ask me a question
so the the childhood
abuse that you had with your father
do you see a connection with with the
certainly you you indicated before there
was a connection with that and the
abusive relationships you had after that
but
i'm just wondering what would this
happen this is in your 20s right your
early 20s
how is it how is this affected your
later life yeah so how called you today
i'm 33 33 um
[Music]
i don't see really a connection with my
father now
the man i'm married yes um
as soon as i got back from oklahoma
um it took me
close to two years but i got custody of
my son back
i've had him ever since um and let me
ask about
his wife did she she was aware of this
she suspected and she was very angry
then i think
now she's um
she feels responsible
and guilty um
we've had a lot of talks about it
i think she forgives me
i know she still loves me but
to have gone through what all she's gone
through um she's one of the most
beautiful people i know
i don't think i could still win me
but my husband um
i came back
to tennessee and uh um
in just a few weeks and into being back
i met the man that
that i'm married um we've been married
11 years
and now
currently presently and for the last few
years
well he always has worn overalls and
he's a giant man
um the only difference is he's brown and
my papa wasn't
and um but he's got
the long gray beard now um he's 27 years
older than me
um i didn't care then i thought
i did think he was beautiful um
he didn't look his age uh
and i wanted stability and i wanted
normal um
and for a little while i had that um so
i do see
a i guess like um
we could talk between the two they're
very much the same
the the overalls the great beards the
narcissistic [ __ ] the um
in a lot of ways they're the same person
and i think the fact that
neither of them liked each other from
the beginning probably
probably should have been a big red flag
we let him it gets sicker
i get sicker um
i left oklahoma and you would think that
i
would have never looked back but he came
to tennessee
when i was um pregnant
with i didn't know it was a girl yet but
my second child and i was with my
husband he stayed with us
for one night um it was supposed to be a
few days
um and he sang a song right in front of
my husband about
when they had written about a girl with
long black hair and green eyes
kissing her under some trees in a
like by creek or some stupid [ __ ]
and my husband wasn't stupid he picked
up on it quickly and
um
the straw that broke the camel's back
was the next day
he walked in my husband i was there
alone with my grandfather
he my grandfather never tried anything
during that trip in tennessee
when he came to see us um but
i was sitting at the kitchen table doing
something and
right when my husband opened the door my
grandfather walked up behind me
and he put his hand around the back of
my neck
and he leaned down and i didn't realize
i was making
a face but i guess i did and my husband
saw it
and he pulled me in the back bedroom and
he said what's going on something's
going on and i told him nothing
um i just didn't want to be there
if he was there so um
long story short peppa left that day
and i never saw him again
because i went on to find out a couple
months later that
i was carrying a girl and
not my kids
then i had another little girl
i never spoke tan through all these
years um
and then three years ago and got
subpoenaed
to testify for my baby cousin against
him and i was pregnant with my third
little girl
all of us came from all over the country
to testify against him
and um
i was the only one on the stand
the defense attorney asked me how i felt
about being there that day and i said
horrible
because i love i loved him very much
and i didn't want to see him put away in
prison and hurt because i feel like he
was just
he was just a very sick man
especially given the conversations that
we had had about why he did the thing
what he thought he did the things that
he did
i testified against him because i loved
my baby cousin
and his potential future victims more
than him
but i still loved him
and i didn't want to see anything awful
happen to him um
i don't love him now um
he was convicted he got seven years
for what he did to her and he died
after only two years in prison um
he actually died um a couple of weeks
before i had already gone through all
all the loops i had to go through all
the
hoops had to jump through to go see him
um being a victim
they don't generally let you have a
visit with the perpetrator in oklahoma
but i wanted him to see me now and see
that
i knew that he accepted my visit when he
denied everybody else's
because he thought he could still
play one last game maybe but i needed
him to see
that uh
i'm probably still pretty sick in the
head but i'm not
his anymore and i i'm not under his
spell
anymore and also tell him that
that i love him and i forgive him
i love the good in him
and i forgive the bad in him that hurt
me so bad and the people i love so bad
but i never got that chance um
he died before i could go
so
this was how many years ago he died in
december
almost a year ago
so it's still fairly fresh yeah been
disowned by his whole family except for
two cousins um
they're all very angry with us
for testifying and they're all very very
angry
that myself and my aunt
speak about it
um
because like i said he was super
charismatic and um
nobody could really believe that he was
capable of the things that he did
but
i guess i need i need to make it clear
that i understand that there's a big
difference in
um what he did
to all of us his children especially
what he did to my baby cousin my aunts
and my mother
um and then what happened
when i was an adult and i guess that's
why i'm here today because
nobody um it's um it's a lot easier to
say that
things done to you when you were an
innocent child and you couldn't
you couldn't fight back or say no
but as an adult at any age when you
can and you just don't
there's like a huge amount of like
um self-hate and guilt that comes with
that and
it's um
it's damn near taking me out a couple of
times uh
so like court the d.a told me that
this is so common that
she she hears about it so often i had to
take her in the back room and tell her
look
just in case i don't want you know a
curveball thrown at you and
my cousin's whole case get blown wide
open in case he decides to
say that this happened between us and
she said
this happens all the time so if it
happens all the time
that's news to me because i never hear
people talk about it
and
i think it needs to be talked about
because it does happen
especially here in the mountains anyway
um
[Music]
i do feel responsible for my part in it
um
but i also feel like people like kim are
really good at what they do
and
i know the guilt that i i live with
there's got to be so many other people
out there living with the same
um and i guess my hope
like what what i hope for with this
with this interview um
is maybe start a conversation about it
where it's not so
taboo to talk about um
[Music]
maybe people like me
reach out for help sooner and um
i also hope that maybe it would um
set me free because
he's gone but i'm not and
it's all still here and very real
so you were having sex with your
grandfather
who was also at one point having sex
with your mom his daughter
yes but i need to make it clear that
that that was
actual honest-to-god rape like she
fought back and said no the last time
that he raped her she was 16 which is
when she fell
pregnant with me and for
much of my life um she told me
when i was
[Music]
i want to say i was about 15 or 16
that he could be my biological father
and i lived in horror of that fact
which also kind of
i don't know if catch 22 is the right
word but
um it felt disgusting but at the same
time i thought
um anybody but my dad
at the time you know i was an angry
teenager and i thought
even if it has to be this funky old
backwoods [ __ ]
at least i have maybe a shot at a dad
that loves me and
says he loves me and tells me i'm
beautiful and
etc etc and then whenever i
moved to oklahoma and i asked him about
this
his take on it was that it was
consensual sex in the back of his van
even though my mother was 16 his
biological daughter and yes
we know for sure it's biological because
we've mom and i've both
taken a 23andme test
and many of his family members are on
there um
he he said that it was consensual and he
went into graphic detail about what
happened
and then he he scoffed and he giggled
and he said
that's ridiculous i had a vasectomy
after your aunt was born
um i never could have been your father
and then i remember also um
probably several weeks into um
what do you call it our
the sexual [ __ ] him
saying that
he would love nothing more than to be
able to come back
home to east tennessee and live in a
cabin with me
and have babies and
spend the rest of his life living like a
mountain man like he was meant to be
which was all a facade he played this
mountain man character in oklahoma but
he wasn't he was from
a moderately big city and the
straw hat and the cowboy boots and the
overalls were all just a [ __ ]
um character he played
um but yeah
there was something really broken and
really sick inside him
um
thank god he did have a vasectomy or he
probably
would have been my father and i
probably would have had at least one of
his kids
just being honest
if you're 20 years old how do you let
your grandfather get away with this how
does this happen
okay so it seems like you'd be old
enough to protect yourself from i was
um and i don't have like a
black and white answer for that but i
think um i think it was like a multitude
of things number one
it was the memories of him
right so i only had a couple of bad ones
but the rest were good
the memories of this big giant santa
claus papaw that played the guitar and
he was saying this sneaky snake song and
like everybody wanted to papa like that
right and then
and then my mom spending years telling
us no no no no no you can't talk to them
well like i said i was rebellious as
[ __ ] so
of course i'm gonna do the opposite
right um not realizing how dangerous it
was and why she was saying no no no no
no
um then
i think that being with my father
and i'm not i'm not trying to bash him
by saying this but being with my father
for so many years
um if i hadn't have lived with him i
think it would have definitely gone down
differently
but six years of
12 to 18
some of the most formative years of my
life
i was taught every day that i had to
submit
or else and that i didn't have a choice
and um
having um a male figures will
imposed on me and it was just a [ __ ]
way of laughing just
it just was how it was and then add on
to that the four-year boyfriend
and it was the same [ __ ] and
there was nobody in this world i
wouldn't fight in fact i stayed in
trouble constantly
in school and out for fighting usually
usually females but
when it came to men even if i had to
fight them
i still in the end ended up
submitting and doing what they wanted so
by the time i got to him
i've gone through all these years of
conditioning from my father and
and this [ __ ] boyfriend and and then
the learning how to um
i guess the word is disassociate um
through my drug years earlier year-ish
um sleeping with strangers
old men whatever so by the time i got by
the time i got to him
um he was like the ultimate he was
physically the biggest and personality
was the biggest
and he had the biggest presence and the
strongest will
and it was almost like being um
[Music]
a hypnotized is not the right word but
there was no saying no it it just
never really crossed my mind as an
option and even when it ended
it wasn't like i found the courage to do
it myself
i got very very sick and was in the
hospital for
over a week and they didn't think i was
going to make it
so my paternal grandparents drove from
tennessee to oklahoma
and i miraculously started to get better
and once
once i got better they asked me
i reckon they got tired of being angry
with me they asked me if i wanted to
come home and man
we drove to that little house and i just
threw all my [ __ ]
i grabbed [ __ ] left it right and threw
it in my truck and
i followed them back home um
and that's where i stayed with them
until i met my husband
um if i hadn't got
sick i probably would have stayed truth
be told for
years and he took your power
away he he took any choice you had away
there was no
choice and then and i also felt like i'd
probably gone wrong somewhere and done
something wrong by continuing to speak
to him
when i was like 14
after the whole kissing thing and after
all the [ __ ] when i was a little girl
maybe i'd given him the signal like as
like a
like a oh it's okay thing like
maybe i had said or done something to
make him think that
that i was okay with it or that it was
um
wanted or whatever but it very very much
wasn't and
i think it was very obvious that it
wasn't from the first time
um that he ever tried anything um
[Music]
i don't i don't know why i couldn't
couldn't fight him off i fought back
with my dad i fought back with
boyfriends i fought back with my husband
after
i don't i'm not sure but
um he definitely
did a good job of grooming also like
from childhood onward always
always there to say no there's nothing
wrong with you and no you're doing great
and i love you and i support you and
whatever you do
and answering the phone anytime i called
and
kind of rushing in to save the day and
um
sending me gifts and um
writing songs for me and about me and
just doing anything you could
like like it was flattering and i
had never heard from a man in my entire
in my entire life that i was beautiful
or that i was a lady or that
um that i could be anything i wanted to
be
even my good people here in tennessee
like
he was just a different he was my very
best friend but a different breed of men
like they just don't hear in my family
they just don't say things like that so
to hear that from him
and to get the gifts and to get the
attention and to get
to get all the things that i think he
knew i was starving for
[Music]
um
it was intoxicating i don't know
and maybe that played a role in why
i didn't say no because i could have
but i didn't
told you it took me two years to get my
son back
um there was a lot of trial and error
methadone suboxone
um [ __ ] up falling off the wagon
um now um
i take um benzos
for sure um
but that's it
you didn't knock on wood um some days
a lot of days i want to get high um
but i'm not um
losing my son for that that couple of
years
and not even completely almost destroyed
me i can't imagine
losing my girls and and my
and my son there my world i would die if
i lost them
um and trying to escape the girl's
father
um it's probably not a good idea to go
to court dirty right
so i'm good right now but
who knows people stay clean for decades
and then
[ __ ] it up
secrets keep you sick right
so
thank you it took a lot of courage for
you to do this
i appreciate it
thank you very much thank you
you